[Musique]
non
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes à plus de 4000 km à l'est de
moscou dans l'une des villes les plus
grandes de sibérie la ville d'irkoutsk
irkoutsk a été fondée à la fin du xviie
siècle et est vite devenu le centre de
la région du baïkal la ville a prospéré
grâce au commerce avec lorient et des
caravanes commerçants ont commencé à la
traversée de chine vers la russie pour
les tissus et de sibérie vers l'orient
pour les fourrures
tigre de l'amour été particulièrement
recherchées là on est devenue le symbole
de la ville il figure dorénavant sur
l'écusson d'irkoutsk riz
[Applaudissements]
au xixème siècle la ville est devenue le
centre culturel de la sibérie orientale
aujourd'hui avec une population de 600
mille habitants et recousent qui est un
centre industriel scientifique et
universitaire important ainsi qu'un
noeud de transport
les grands espaces et la beauté
naturelle de la sibérie ont conquis le
coeur de notre invité d'aujourd'hui il
s'appelle benoît de 8 il nous vient de
belgique et îlots verts ici même sa
brasserie belge allons faire sa
connaissance
[Musique]
salut benoît salut à tous je vois bien
ouais on chantait sans trois merci est
ce que tu peux me dire qu'est ce qu'on
fait ou est ce qu'on est là c'est aussi
chez toi et ben voilà bienvenue dans ma
brasserie bb b comment comme je dis
toujours ça c'est ici le côté
boulangerie pâtisserie avec une cuisine
ouverte et puis on a un peu plus loin la
côte est la vraie brasserie belge disons
avec un bar bear belge enfin le le truc
belges croient tout à fait ok ça fait
combien de temps que tu as ouvert
le côté restaurant ça fait six ans et
demi le côté brasserie
pardon leucate et pâtisserie boulangerie
ça fait cinq ans ça fait cinq ans donc
et toi tu fais quoi ici aubin je fais de
tout bas en russie mais il faut il faut
faire de tout je fais du management je
fais de la cuisine je fais de la
pâtisserie j'ai appris à faire un peu
tout j'aime bien de communiquer avec
liant donc donc c'est comme un portugais
être un super voilà non non non juste
juste quelqu'un qui aime bien de faire
ce qu'il fait et voilà tu veux que le
bar tout à fait allez on y va
[Musique]
alors si si ton petit coin de belgique
tout à fait voilà bienvenue dans la
brasserie belge
petit voilà notre tête
jonathan forcément j'enregistre le
manneken pis alors année depuis ce
qu'est ce qu'on ferait sans lui c'est la
fierté de la belgique la petite
statuette pas trop grandes mais voilà tu
peux me dire pourquoi le bbb bar le bébé
c'est une longue histoire mais pour
vraiment être très court c'est maman qui
m'a envoyé des emails
un toujours bbb je me pose toujours la
question pourquoi bbb et finalement un
jour elle me répond assez vu que je sais
pas quand tu vas lire tes email c'est
bonjour bonsoir benoît et le jour où je
voulais vous vivrez restaurant je me
tiens j'avais j'avais pierre j'avais
belges savaient déjà 2 b ça va le
troisième but ce sera brasserie
brasseries bars cafés brasseries et
bières belges
voilà le bébé exactement c'est quelqu'un
de très exigeant c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
peur de rien et qui est très exigeant
qui recherchent toujours à l'excellence
il a commencé de rien elle a construit
un business était le restaurant la
boulangerie la pizzeria et s'agrandit
comme ça c'est formidable alors dans son
bar il ya de la bière et les verbiages
belle et fière belges ont les importuns
on les importent des bières belges mais
on n'a pas que du belge on a aussi
quelques produits locaux dont quelques
bonnes bières locales en fait avec des
brasseurs locaux
vient faire là bas il s'améliore
de plus en plus donc il ya vraiment de
bons produits sur le marché on peut
trouver vraiment déjà des bonnes des
bonnes bières ça reste peut-être pas
l'ailé des grandes bières du monde
entier mais mes finales surtout qu'il
connaît bien eh ben j'ai travaillé
beaucoup et j'ai fait presque dix ans
dans tout ce qui est principal du malt
jusqu'à la production de la bière donc
je connais monsieur le
désaccord donc tu sais exactement ça
qu'est-ce qui
on a on a tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est famille en belgique on allait
carbonade flamande et les frites les
gaufres dont flash est les flammes que
je sais pas trop pas trop d'ailleurs
c'est en russie que j'ai appris qu'il y
avait des flammes et que ce que c'était
un truc typiquement belge je crois que
c'était plus alsacien
mais non n'est pas trop plein mais voilà
les frites tu l'auras knicks et les
belges les frais et les frites qu'est ce
qu'on fait il s'effrite tout le monde
sait que c'est belge a d'ailleurs on
aura toujours que c'est les french fries
en anglais c'est des belles âmes fries
je leur dis toujours mais bon tu nous
montre un peu la cuisine et bien on y va
aller manger au monde au
cac et fait faire des plats russes ont
fait des plats russes
il ya des plats russes un peu
international genre le bistrot gagnent
of que j'adore qui est une
un plat assez intéressant on fait aussi
d'une façon assez traditionnel et puis
il ya des plats locaux comme le sagou
die qui est un poisson qu'elle avec le
poisson du lac c'est une préparation de
poissons qu avec un peu d'oignons un peu
d'huile sel poivre c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument goûter parce que
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
d'unique et très local après il ya des
produits comme les grosses dit c'est les
champignons les champignons aussi qu'ils
se marine c'est aussi très très très
très locale très très sibérien que tu
fais de la promotion la cuisine belge
est ce que tu apprends à tat chef
cuisinier comment on prépare
passé c'est beaucoup trop forcément on
apprend nos cuisines him
à faire une bonne béchamel une
mayonnaise la mayonnaise belge tout le
monde la connaît
et puis il ya quelque chose que j'adore
c'est vraiment les masterclass comme on
les appelle c'est quand il ya
quand les clients en fait on leur ont
leur explique comment faire des choses
se soient belges ou pas belges ont leur
montrons leur fait un master place de
cuisine arriva les étonner vers la
manière dont tu prépares les places qui
à un moment il y sera mais j'ai jamais
fait ça comme ça eh ben c'est oui ça
arrive ça arrive et souvent parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses une mayonnaise pas
tout le monde a fait une mayonnaise dans
sa vie après il ya plusieurs façons de
faire une mayonnaise on peut commencer
avec la fourchette avec le fouet ou avec
le mixeur donc on peut faire une
mayonnaise de différentes façons mais
aussi à des petits trucs sympas à des
petits comme on l'appelle les lifes rec
comment séparer le blanc d'un jaune ici
en russie pour une raison ou une autre
ils prennent toujours un couteau et et
coupant fait en fait l'oeuf il casse
avec le couteau donc ça prend énormément
de temps c'est un peu dangereux mais
c'est dans leurs habitudes et moi je
leur montre finalement comment on peut
le faire d'une façon tout à fait
différente beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
simple et facile de savoir faire
français belges italiens européens en
général c'est d'aider des siècles et des
siècles de
de connaissances en fait qui manque ici
en ce moment et donc pour tout étranger
qui peut apporter quelque chose qui soit
en fromage dit que ce soit en vian que
ce soit en notre connaissance il
pourrait vraiment développer ici un
marché local est plus que localement je
pense qu'il a amené pas mal de choses
dans la ville par son dynamisme par son
envie de réaliser les choses éparses et
ses nouveaux projets donc c'est
quelqu'un je dirais qu'ils aient adhéré
avec il ya des envies qui se donne les
moyens de les réaliser
comme tout et ville de sibérie irkoutsk
été construite à l'origine entièrement
en bois mais ici malgré plusieurs
incendies importants au 19e siècle un
certain nombre de vestiges de cette
époque se sont conservés nous avons
décidé de nous promener avec benoît pour
en admirer quelques uns
quelle était ma première impression
quand tu arrives en russie
j'étais attirée bon forcément j'étais
attiré un peu par le ministre le côté
mystérieux de la russie parce que c'est
un pays assez méconnu disons enfin
c'était du moins et puis
ban arrivé à moscow bon moscou c'est pas
vraiment la russie moscou ça reste
moscou c'est une grosse vie une grosse
capitale tuant en sibérie la différence
après moscou je trouve personnellement
que les gens sont plus chaleureux
c'est peut-être bon il fait peut-être un
peu plus froid au niveau climat comme
aujourd'hui il faut toujours montrer
moins 16 mai mais finalement les gens
les gens sont un peu plus ouverts un peu
moins agressif un peu plus
passionnés en fait par avoir un contact
avec un avec un étranger d'être donc on
est un peu plus appréciés disons dans
les régions enfin surtout ici en sibérie
je me trouve beaucoup plus apprécié que
ce que serait en moscou par exemple
pourquoi tu a déménagé en russie
bonne occasion bonne question c'est sûr
sous l'oeil a vu deux étapes la première
étape où j'arrivais à moscou le but
était vraiment plus de quitter la
belgique que de venir en russie mais
j'ai choisi la russie parce que c'était
géographiquement un peu plus près que
l'europe saint-mathias j'étais intéressé
par le côté russe
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai en fait
quitté la belgique pour venir habiter à
moscou puis j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler à moscou ce qui m'a donné une
opportunité de rester et de vivre la
culture russe
que je trouve passionnante et puis avec
le
le travail que j'avais eue
j'ai toujours pas compris si j'ai fait
une connerie au boulot ou pas mais en
réponse j'ai eu l'occasion on m'a envoyé
en sibérie
pour travailler dans une brasserie ici à
40km d'irkut c'est comme ça que je suis
arrivée
en sibérie à irkoutsk et puis j'y suis
resté parce que je suis passionné par
par la nature par le baïkal
[Musique]
benoît 2,8 et né en 1978 à courtrai dans
la flandre belge ses parents il son
libraire et benoît fait toute sa
scolarité à courtrai à 18 ans il part à
l'université de louvain pour suivre des
études d'ingénieur agronome après avoir
obtenu son diplôme benoît commence à
travailler dans le domaine de la
brasserie d'abord à bruxelles puis à
anvers cherchant à élargir ses horizons
benoît décide de se lancer dans l
aventure dans l'un des nouveaux pays
émergents telle époque la russie
en janvier 2006 il arrive pour la
première fois à moscou pour étudier le
russe de manière intensive pendant six
mois en même temps benoît cherche un
travail et est embauché par le brasseur
belge ab inbev à moscou dans le cadre de
son travail benoît visite des brasseries
en russie en ukraine et en europe
centrale
en 2011 il est envoyé en sibérie pour
devenir directeur de la brasserie
d'angarsk c'est à cette époque qu'il
rencontre son époux sibérienne tatiana
après deux ans benoît décide de quitter
la brasserie pour ouvrir un restaurant
d'abord à angarsk puis dans la ville
d'irkoutsk
en 2016 il ouvre une peau langeree
pâtisserie agrémenté d'une cave à vin
depuis l'année dernière
c'est sympa lyon suis toi
oui c'est ma fierté ma petite maison en
bois comme jeudi en sibérie c'est toi
qui l'a fait c'est moi qui l'ait
dessiner je n'ai pas construite de mes
propres mains mais c'est quasi tout
comme j'ai mis beaucoup de beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de beaucoup d'imagination
et je vois que tu as la fameuse à boucan
qu'un russe
depuis que je suis en russie j'ai
toujours voulu j'aime bien les trucs
finalement russe il alla la boucane
casas pas cessé de design russe c'est la
qualité russe ça casse très souvent
ouais tu l'a réparé comme ça pas mal pas
mal tu as quoi là c'est le sien c'est un
chaudron là c'est quoi ces ach andro
exactement c'est ce qu'on appelle le sim
husky tchane
c'est en fait une grosse marmite avec
avec de l'eau on met du homet du feu en
dessous ça chauffe eau chaude
généralement jusqu'à 50 55 degrés et
puis on reste là pendant une heure ou
deux heures dans un bain chaud on
discute
c'est une activité super sympa à faire
avec les amis vers là j'entends beaucoup
de beaucoup de bruit la sas et les
chiens
voilà achat n'est pas dit non c'est non
encore voilà cm maîtresses skis
steam magnifique
donc c'est ma bon c'est aussi ma fierté
c'est comme et c'est comme mes enfants
c'est c'est inouï je vais courir courir
avec eux tous les jours c'est ici
surtout après les chiens mais en fait
non aux coups
courts moi je je je conduise disons
comme ça
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que comment ça se passe
en fait pourquoi pourquoi tu as décidé
d'avoir autant de autant de ski hausse
et une housse et non du soir c'est
surtout ma femme qui voulait d'abord un
dalmatien à tanger à dalmatiens réduit
il est à l'intérieur tu vois il fait un
peu plus chaud alors là j'ai toujours je
me suis souvenu que je voulais avoir un
esprit depuis que je suis tout petit et
puis on est en sibérie finalement donc
on a acheté un husky sibérien
et puis elle a eu un deuxième un
troisième et on en a en fait rage en
avait 6 et puis avec l'équipe ça fait 6
ou 7 ça fait treize alors un combat
c'est un c'est un hobby c'est une
passion ou c'est pour le travail c'est
quoi ces c'est encore aujourd'hui un
hobby une passion mais après ça pourrait
très bien devenir
à quelque chose de professionnel en fait
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
que beaucoup de touristes voyageurs
apprécie énormément de pouvoir faire un
tour en chiens de traîneau ouais donc
forcément c'est kechiche on peut
exploiter dans la région ils n'ont pas
froid dans la neige incroyable c'est
incroyable
moins 30 moins 30 y dorment ils ont même
ils ont une petite maison mais il donne
toujours sur la neige c'est vrai qu'en
la nuit c'est moins 30 moins quatre ans
il n'y a pas de problème et alors tout
ça c'est un élevage tout ça coûte cher
comme un certain budget à part moi il
faut c'est une nourriture vétérinaire
temps en temps des petites bagarres
qu'il faut soigner donc donc forcément
c'est tout un budget
mais bon c'est une passion c'est comme
jouer au golf n'est pas bon marché non
plus
yann ça te dit on va se balader avec les
chiens ouais ouais ça me dit bien la
balle et allonge les gens on va habiller
les autres jeux que tu les as ni sky
bien aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quels sont tes loisirs qu'est ce que tu
fais en dehors de chirurgie ge les
chiens c'est déjà une passion web à la
bourre en location le restaurant ça
prend beaucoup de temps les chiens
je dirais tout autant
et j'adore j'adore les autres sports en
été je fais un peu de rugby on a créé
ici une association
enfin un club de rugby qui fait partie
de l'association de rugby de russie et
les russes jouent au rugby les russes
jouent au rugby tout à fait tout à fait
un bon forcément nous on a un peu limité
en parce que bon les hivers sont assez
rude donc on joue pas en hiver mais
sinon on était aussi j'adore tout ce qui
est sport de voile la planche à voile de
kite des choses comme ça aussi c d c'est
des choses que même le kite on peut
partir on peut on peut le faire sur la
glace ou si ça devient très populaire
vous parlez en quelle langue avec ta
femme en russe en lice en russe
finalement ben on s'est connus on a
toujours on a toujours parlé du sang
semble et puis une fois qu'on commence
avec une certaine langue on continue et
puis bon elle progresser le fait des
progrès en français quand même elle
étudie l étudier un peu le français mais
ça reste dur pour avoir une conversation
de tous les jours donc donc voilà c'est
primordial selon toi d'avoir connaître
la langue russe pour vivre travailler en
russie
je crois que si on est en dehors de
moscou c'est carrément aux primes
annuelles à moscou je suppose qu'on peut
se débrouiller parce qu'il ya une
une communauté d'expatriés assez
importante donc je suppose qu'il ya
quand même moyen de se débrouiller
autrement mais en dehors de moscou il
faut il faut connaître la langue sans
hésitation mais il faut vraiment il faut
vraiment gérer sinon il n'y a pas moyen
de comprendre on fait
le jour suivant nous sommes allés avec
benoît au baïkal le lac le plus profond
de la planète qui se trouve à 80
kilomètres d'irkoutsk
surnommée la perle de la sibérie le
baïkal est le plus grand réservoir d'eau
douce dans le monde sa surface
représente à elle seule un peu plus que
le territoire de la belgique
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco il présente une diversité
biologique unique avec plus de 2500
espèces animales dont près de la moitié
ne se trouve nulle part ailleurs
alors le lac baïkal pour toi ça
représente quoi
pour moi c'est une grande bouffée
d'énergie chaque fois que j'arrive au
lax et c'est quelque chose d'unique
c'est incroyable quelle était ta
première réaction quand tu l'as vu
rwasa faye à la première fois que je
suis venu c'est il ya 15 ans mais
c'était comme je dis si c'est de bouffer
je suis arrivé au lac
à la fin du lac en fait parce que c'est
là où commence mangara et là j'ai reçu
une bouffée d'énergie en pleine gueule
en pleine phase en pleine figure et ça
m'est resté en fait depuis depuis lors
je m'arrête toujours je suis pas venu au
lac sans m'arrêter à ce petit endroit
qui est vraiment le début de l'engarran
fait la fin du lac le début de la tat on
petit coin tête et petit nice endroit
secret ah oui il ya des petits endroit
que j'aime bien visiter au bord du lac
et que ce soit ici aliciens chaos plus
loin
donc il ya énormément de deux beaux
endroits pleine nature
comme un chasseur me disait toujours il
y avait encore la préhistoire il ya des
endroits où l'homme n'a pas mis le pied
nous avons décidé de faire une promenade
en bateau sur le baïkal pour vous
imprégner de son atmosphère et de sa
force
[Musique]
bondy dont il fait un peu froid l'a
fait
le lac baïkal il est pas gelé à c'est
une très bonne question en fait ça
demande énormément énormément d'énergie
pour jeunes et une surface paris et
c'est que finalement début février qu'on
peut vraiment voir le lac gelé et à
partir duquel on peut vraiment dire
qu'on peut traverser le lac en voiture
mais moi ce que j'aimerais vraiment
comprendre
on est en plein froid là qu'est ce qui
te fait rester ici bah justement mon
avis le franc le fait de le fait de
faire quelque chose d'unique et d'avoir
des opportunités et finalement je crois
que la russie d'un encore énormément
d'opportunités aux jeunes de pouvoir
faire des choses uniques et ce que je
fais je pourrais pas le faire ni à
moscou uni en belgique avoir un
restaurant brasserie belge faire du
chien de traîneau conçu une petite
maison en bois ça se fait plus enfin on
a pu la place occupe eu la possibilité
de faire ça en europe est ce que tu fais
la différence effectivement entre des
mentalités entre l'europe la belgique et
puis le la russie les russes et a
forcément une très grande différence
culturelle et donc de mentalité aussi
bon l'histoire fait que les russes ont
quand même différent ils ont ils ont le
même type on est tous se repayer un type
européen mais au niveau culturel une
fois qu'on habite ici depuis longtemps
c'est vraiment différent
les relations sont différentes les amis
des relations d'amis en fait c'est un
autre niveau c'est autre chose c'est
autre chose c'est pas moins bien c'est
pas mieux c'est autre chose tu arrives à
avoir des amitiés profondes ici avec des
russes mais ça fait 16 ans que j'y suis
j'ai pas vraiment d'amis comme je
pourrais dire que j'en ai en belgique
donc il ya des il ya des potes si on va
aller boire des verres il ya des amis
mais vraiment les les deux trois amis
qu'on compte les vrais vrais amis ça
reste finalement en belgique et mais ici
tu as quand un groupe david oui
avec le restaurant avec tout ce que j'ai
fait ça fait ça fait quand même beaucoup
de temps donc il ya eu quand même
quelques quelques bonnes relations et
des amis sur qui on peut compter quand
le bébé est l'un des endroits préférés
de la communauté francophone d'irkoutsk
ici réunis de temps en temps ce soir il
organise un karaoké où benoît nous a
invités à bonjour françois ça va bien
héloïse
enfants d'ailleurs je vous présente yann
aller à jour vos parents sur dix ans
là
le manger
et
on y voit encore des arts
chercher l'europe dollar pour le coeur
qu'est ce qui te manque le plus en
russie y'a pas ce contact social come on
come on connaît en belgique qu'est ce
que la belgique pourrait apporter à la
russie il ya énormément d'entreprises
qui font de bonnes choses
mais je crois qu'avec avec un savoir
faire européen que ce soit belges
français ou autre je crois que ce sera
en cours nettement nuit où est ce que tu
te vois dans dix ans mais je crois que
je me vois encore toujours ici je me
suis je me suis pas mal investi que ce
soit au niveau business et au niveau
privé
maintenant aussi avec avec les chiens
jeu jours je voit pas les amener autre
parqués ici parce que je crois qu'il
pourrait être qu'heureux en sibérie ou
fait vraiment froid donc les amener en
belgique se seraient exclues de toute
façon
donc donc je me vois vraiment être ici
encore on est dans les dix prochaines
années je ne mens pas pourquoi je
partirais
qu'est ce que c'est pour toi la sibérie
en trois mots froid
chien et puis
troisième mot
[Musique]
chaleur je te remercie on a passé un
excellent moment je souhaite une bonne
continuation
beaucoup de beaucoup de clients et puis
plein de ski à nouveau yann à tous grand
merci à toi bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons passé avec benoît de 8 qui
nous a fait découvrir ces histoires
sibérienne extraordinaire de nouveaux
lieux de nouvelles personnalités toutes
aussi intéressantes vous attendre je
vous dis à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]